[Applaus]
[Musik]
weylandt ist ein land welches auch
menschen aller art anziehend wirken kann
buddhistische mönche abenteuerlustige
touristen oder so typen wie aus hangover
2 es gibt viele gründe warum wir alle
schon unglaubliche geschichten von
wilden partys aus bangkok gehört haben
und nicht aus brunei malaysia wurde
einem anderen ort in südostasien gründe
wie diese
[Musik]
thailand führen den asien bei der
legalisierung von medizinischem
marihuana
mailand könnte das erste land in
südostasien werden dass
gleichgeschlechtliche partnerschaften
erlaubt oh ja strände marihuana rechte
für lkws thailand scheint so etwas wie
die asiatische version des liberalen
kaliforniens zu sein nun mit einer
monarchie und weniger belastend für den
geldbeutel doch in letzter zeit ist
thailand wegen schlagzeilen wie dieser
in die nachrichten
[Musik]
die proteste in thailand schreiben
geschichte zum ersten mal seit
jahrzehnten lehnen sich die menschen
offen gegen die autorität der monarchie
auf um die reine vorstellung zu geben
seit juli 2020 den regelmäßig
hunderttausende von thailändern auf die
straße gegangen um einen völligen
regimewechsel zu fordern
sie fordern eine änderung der verfassung
eine reform der monarchie und freie
wahlen anstatt die faust oder die hand
zu heben gegen die thailänder diese 30
und ja das hat tatsächlich was mit ranga
games zu tun mehr dazu später aber
zurück zu unserer geschichte dann glaubt
mir wenn ich sage dass die thailänder
wahrlich keinen mangel an gründen haben
um zu protestieren
wir sprechen über eines der autoritären
länder der welt
das politische system teil 1 ist eine
mischung aus einer zwar die jura
konstitutionellen monarchie die real
jedoch absolutistische züge trägt eine
theokratie und einer militärdiktatur in
der tat ist das thailändische königshaus
das reichste der welt und übertrifft mit
einem vermögen sogar die öl monarchie
und es verfügt über weit mehr macht als
jede europäische branche und du denkst
wahrscheinlich schon markt wenn sie so
autoritär sind wie ist es dann möglich
dass thailand so viel tourismus hat die
ist es möglich dass es so viele digital
nomads gibt die nach thailand ziehen um
dort zu leben städte wie bangkok und
jeremy sind hippe kassiere ich meine
diese menschen arbeiten online und
könnten überall sonst auf der welt leben
sie entscheiden sich aber ausgerechnet
für thailand das kann doch kein zufall
sein und ja thailand kann ein
fantastisches land für einen westler
sein aber wenn du ein teil bist siehst
du das vielleicht ein wenig anders
drei länder droht lange haftstrafe für
sarkastische bemerkung über den hund des
königs um die reine vorstellung zu geben
thailand hat die viertgrößte gefängnis
population der welt gleich ein satanist
hannover und natürlich den vereinigten
staaten und nur mal so als randnotiz tja
die usa haben die größte gefängnis
population der welt aber zu diesem thema
werden da ein eigenes video machen
vergisst also bitte nicht wieso an
politik abonnieren und auch das
glöckchen zu aktivieren um keines
unserer interessanten videos mehr zu
verpassen aber zurück nach thailand der
springende punkt ist dass im vergleich
zum thailändischen gefängnissen die us
haftanstalten die fünf sterne hotels und
diese später sehen werden ist es sehr
leicht in einem thailändischen gefängnis
zu landen für total absurde dinge bei
denen es bei uns noch nicht mal einen
strafzettel gebe der intensiven proteste
richten sich also vor allem gegen diese
horrenden ungerechtigkeiten
[Musik]
heiland proteste tausende demonstrieren
den dritten tag in folge trotz verbot
durch die regierung das problem dabei
keiner dieser nachrichten wird viel
aufmerksamkeit auf sich ziehen rühren
wir so an politik videos haben wir
bereits über die thailändische politik
gesprochen denn wenn es eine sache gibt
die dieses land charakterisiert dann
sind es im wechsel um ihr alle
vorstellungen zu geben seit 1932 hat
thailand durchschnittlich alle vier
jahre eine staatsstreiche erlebt putsche
sind in diesem land so alltäglich dass
sie es nicht einmal mehr bis zu uns in
die nachrichten schaffen doch diese
proteste sind etwas anders die frage ist
daher wer wo wir dieses mal nicht nur
einen regime wechsel sondern auch ein
systemwechsel erleben können pass auf
denn unser heutiges video verfügt über
alle ingredienzien eines richtigen
politikers geld macht lebende götter auf
erden und sex jede menge sex mit
königlichen sex soldatinnen am
starnberger see in oberbayern
wie bitte ja du bist nicht auf dem
falschen videoportal gelandet was
einfach mal ab diese geschichte ist so
exzentrisch und dabei politisch hoch
brisant dass man aus dem staunen nicht
mehr heraus kommt die fragen die wir
orte stellen laufen also was macht die
proteste in thailand zu bedeutsam was
fordern die demonstranten
was ist das wahre problem in thailand
und warum haben sie den hunger groß als
symbol ihres protests gewählt heute
werden wir diese fragen beantworten aber
also erst wer einen schnellen blick auf
den wenig geschichte
ein göttlicher befehl dies ist nicht das
erste mal dass wir auch diese wahl
politik über eine theokratie sprechen in
vielen anderen ländern wie saudi arabien
oder den iran
die in religion und politik hand in hand
er falle thailand geht es jedoch noch
ein wenig weiter der thailändische könig
wird förmlich als die direkte
verkörperung gottes auf erden angesehen
tja so einfach kann das sein
[Musik]
die momentane könig von thailand heißt
rama der zehnte vor ihm gab es ein drama
den neunten mal den 80 so weiter bis zur
hammer der name rama wird nach der
krönung verliehen und ist wirklich der
thailändischen namen der göttin nischen
um die eine vorstellung zu geben bis
1932 war thailand eine absolute
monarchie seitdem gibt es eine
verfassung welche die macht des königs
einschränkt
aber auch so hat der monarch immer noch
eine menge macht besten endet ist an
gott was auch immer das heißen norden
nun wie glücklich sie wirklich sein
mögen thailändische könige werden von
sehr menschlichen leidenschaften
getrieben könig rama der 9 auch bekannt
unter seinem vornamen ball wurde
gekrönte als er 23 jahre alt war nachdem
jemand dann hätten oder rama den achten
ermordet hatten das alles klingt an sich
schon verrückt aber warten denn das ist
noch gar nichts
[Musik]
ist wäre doch logisch zu denken das
kündigt erneute auch bekannt als herren
über unser haupt oder herr des lebens
aus thailand kommen muss oder immerhin
ist er der könig des landes nun man
könnte nicht mehr daneben liegen erneut
wurde in cambridge massachusetts geboren
spielt dort seine familien schweiz wo an
der universität von lausanne studiert
und jetzt stell dir einfach mal folgende
situation vor dieser im westen
aufgewachsene junge mann geht mit seinen
schweizer studienfreunden zechen und
wird gefragt was willst du sagen bin nun
mal groß bist ich nun ich werde mich dem
dasein einer gottheit in thailand widmen
sowohl weber darüber hinaus hat sich
ramadan note nach so vielen jahren der
westlichen bildung ohne sozialisation
bestimmte gewohnheiten angeeignet
insbesondere lernte er jazz zu spielen
und komponierte sogar seine eigenen
stücke
[Musik]
aber zurück zu unserer geschichte in
thailand da das thailändische volk sein
könig als gott betrachtet wird jede
beleidigung der monarchie automatisch
als blasphemie gewertet oder wie sie es
dort nennen lässt und glaubt mir diese
stelle in thailand ein gewaltiges
problem dar thailands laser system
gesetze sind dafür bekannte sehr
allgemein gehalten zu sein und das heißt
es ist nicht klar was eigentlich als
blasphemie zählt und was nicht das
einzige worüber sie klar sind sind die
strafen die bis zu 15 jahre gefängnis
betragen können es gibt unzählige fälle
die einfach völlig unangemessen und
einfach nur zum aus der haut fahren sind
eines zivilisierten landes absolut
unwürdig alle fälle über die ich nun
sprechen werde sind absolut real also
fangen wir an
[Musik]
übersetzen einer nicht autorisierten
biografie des königs zwei jahre
gefängnis beleidigung des hundes des
königs im internet 37 jahre herthas
datei knast werfen von schwarzer farbe
auf ein porträt des königs und man
verschwindet für zehn jahre im loch und
halte ich fest denn wir haben noch nicht
über den straftatbestand der
aufwiegelung gesprochen denn wenn du
dachtest diese blasphemie strafen seien
schon absurd menschenverachtend dass du
jetzt vom programm fallen was die
thailändische gerichte zustandebringen
übertrifft gar die fantasie eines franz
kafka also die folgende dinge können
dich in thailand ins gefängnis bringen
das tragen eines roten hemdes das essen
von sandwiches als form des politischen
protests oder das zeigen eines zettels
auf dem steht papiere zeigen ist kein
verbrechen ich wiederhole das alles sind
reale fälle die menschen ins gefängnis
gebracht haben und natürlich gehört zu
all diesen schrecklichen verbrechen der
aufwiegelung auch der drei finger salut
aus dem film the hunger games
offensichtlich begannen 2014 einige
demonstranten ihn zu nutzen die gestik
vorher unter jungen leuten und seitdem
ist das heben von drei finger auf diese
weise in thailand verbrechen
[Musik]
gut mittlerweile werden sich viele von
euch fragen wie ist es möglich dass sich
das thailändische volk nicht schon
früher gegen seinen könig erhoben hat
die monarchie in thailand gibt es schon
seit jahrhunderten nun die wahrheit ist
dass der könig von thailand bis vor ein
paar jahren eine wirklich beliebte figur
war
[Musik]
und eine vorstellung davon zu geben mehr
als zwölf millionen menschen gingen zur
beerdigung von könig bhumibol um sich
von ihm zu verabschieden und bedenke
dass thailand 64 millionen einwohner hat
das bedeutet dass am 25 oktober 2017
einer von sechs thailänderin alles
stehen und liegen die ist und zum grand
palace in bangkok zu gehen und sich von
seinem gott könig persönlich zu
verabschieden
[Applaus]
sogar in kinos müssen die talente auf
stehen bevor sie einen film sehen und
sich dabei die königlichen anhören und
ich weiß was du sagen wird wenn die
monarchie in diesem land zu beliebt ist
warum haben sich dann so viele büsche
nun das nennen wir es mal gleich unter
die lupe
[Musik]
alle vier jahre ein neuer diktator einer
der hauptvorteile der demokratie ist
dass sie einen machtwechsel ohne
blutvergießen ermöglicht anstatt geld
für waffen und einen bürgerkrieg
auszugeben gegen die kandidaten es für
werbung im wahlkampf aus nun wenn man
keine demokratie hat kann die was zu
rissen allokation etwas anders aussehen
in thailand geben die kandidaten eben
genauso viel für waffen aus die anderswo
für werbung allen die immer über werbung
mosern sei daher gesagt werden euch was
lieber aber spaß beiseite
thailand hat seit 1932 19 putsche erlebt
wo diesen 19 waren 12 erfolgreich und
weitere sieben waren ist nicht alle
diese staatsstreiche folgen einem ganz
ähnlichen muster im grunde sind sie in
thailand zu einem traurigen
traditionellen ritual geworden eine
fraktion der armee organisiert den
staatsstreich und es ist dann der könig
der entscheidet ob er ihn unterstützen
will oder nicht der verlierer musste ins
exil gehen und der gewinner wird für ein
paar jahre der diktator des landes
normalerweise etwa 4 eigentlich genau so
ludwig parlamentswahl allerdings stimmt
nur eine person dabei ab der könig
[Musik]
einige dieser kutsche waren wirklich
gewalttätig zb demonstrierten - 173
mehrere studenten gegen die damalige
militärisch 77 studenten kamen dabei ums
leben rund 850 wurden schwer verletzt
[Musik]
in derselben nacht verkündete der könig
dass die militärregierung zurücktreten
müssen aber einige jahre später wurde
dann auch dieser diktator ist exil
geschickt andere porsche verließen
jedoch viel friedlicher der putsch von
957 dauerte zum beispiel nur wenige
stunden in diesem fall schickte generals
marita natt seine loyalen truppen um die
wichtigsten militärischen einrichtungen
zu übernehmen unterstützt wurde er dabei
von einer großen gruppe von zivilisten
die auf den straßen protestieren stunden
später wurde dieser mann thailands neuer
premierminister der vorherige führer
ging ins exil nach europa und kehrte
sechs jahre später ins land zurück um
wieder premierminister zu werden tja es
scheint so dass sich in thailand den
militärdiktaturen die blutige klinke in
die hand geben aber eines bleibt dabei
die ganze zeit bestehen die monarchie
und du fragst dich vielleicht wie aber
können die menschen dieses krankes
system überhaupt unterstützen nun eine
ziemlich überzeugende antwort ist die
wirtschaft mit oder ohne freiheit
thailand ist eines der reichsten länder
der region zum vergleich das
bruttoinlandsprodukt pro kopf im
kaufkraftparität liegt bei etwa 18.000
dollar dass der demokratischen
philippinen beträgt weniger als die
hälfte
8500 dollar und in der diktatur china
sind es 17.000
[Musik]
während es in vielen teilen chinas
jedoch immer noch keine modernen
krankenhäuser gibt hat thailand ein gut
entwickeltes öffentliches
gesundheitswesen nur um die reine
vorstellung zu geben während ihre
vietnamesischen nachbarn gerade mal aus
den schlimmsten hungersnöte herauskamen
verfügten details in den späten 80er
jahren bereits über die größten
automobil und festplatten fabriken der
region das zu schweigen davon dass sie
eine echte tourismushochburg sind im
jahr 2018 war thailand nummer 10 der
meist besuchten länder der welt weit vor
japan oder griechenland
wie kann thailand also eine so relativ
gut entwickelte wirtschaft bei einem so
furchtbaren politisches system haben nun
hauptsächlich aus zwei gründen seine
währung der bart ist eine der stabilsten
der welt und thailand hatte schon immer
gute beziehungen zum westen besonders zu
japan und du wirst sich fragen was hat
sich denn jetzt geändert warum sind
diese proteste gerade jetzt so wichtig
nun passt jetzt bitte gut auf
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die falle des mittleren einkommens im
oktober 2016 ist der geliebte führer
könig rama der neunte in alter von 88
jahren im krankenhaus verstorben in
einem land das so abhängig von einem
einzigen person ist ist der tod des
königs eine wahre zeitbombe
[Applaus]
aber in diesem fall stand das land kurz
davor eine neue verfassung im rahmen
eines referendums zu verabschieden wenn
dubai das rennen um jetzt aber an
direkte demokratie oder schweiz denkst
muss ich dich schwer enttäuschen eine
volksabstimmung in thailand sieht so aus
dass die armee den bürgern genau sagt
wie sie abstimmen sollen ist doch so
viel bequemer für die menschen als
weniger eine selbst die qual der wahl
hätte nicht wahr und da ist gerade
keinen gott könig gab es ist eher die
militärjunta einen senat ein und
kündigte diese art freier wahlen an
dahinter die armee würde zwar den ganzen
wahlprozess überwachen aber zumindest
würden die oppositionsparteien
kandidieren dürfen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und was passiert wenn man oppositions
parteien erlaubt anzutreten nun ganz
große überraschung sie werden auch
gewählt zum ersten mal seit jahrzehnten
sah es im thailändischen parlament
plötzlich eine demokratisch
oppositionspartei die rede ist von der
future format partie
die lieder partei ist eine änderung der
verfassung welche die macht des königs
einschränkt und freie wahlen und
menschenrechte garantiert bei den wahlen
im märz 2009 10 betragen sie 18 prozent
der stimmen was nicht schlecht ist wenn
man denkt dass es mehr als sieben große
parteien gibt die im parlament sitzen
das erschlichene future forward über
circa ein drittel der politischen macht
im lande und ihr vorsitzender
ist einer der momentan einflussreichsten
führer teil 1
[Musik]
übrigens ist auch der sohn eines der
reichsten millionäre des landes aber
diese tatsache hat seine politischen
image ganz und gar nicht geschadet denn
eigentlich wäre er ja in der lage
gewesen ein sorgenfreies leben im luxus
zu führen aber er entschied sich dafür
dass alles zu riskieren um für die
freiheit seiner mitbürger zu kämpfen und
das land weiter zu bringen und glaubt
mir das risiko ist durchaus real
so eine partei wurde verboten ihm droht
gefängnis aber teil angst an autoren
john grant kit schwört weiter zu kämpfen
ja diese nachricht könnte das ende der
future format partie bedeuten nichts
desto trotz haben sich die dinge in
thailand ihre verändert
die erste sache ist die wirtschaft hast
du dich dass ich dir gesagt habe dass
thailand eines der wohlhabendsten länder
der region ist nun tatsache ist dass ist
das mal war während alle länder
südasiens mit fünf sechs oder sieben
prozent wachsen kommt thailand kommen
über zwei prozent hinaus in den
wirtschaftswissenschaften hat dieses
phänomen einen namen die mittel in
contract die falle des mittleren
einkommens
das heißt es gibt viele länder die es
schaffen der armut zu entkommen und das
zu erreichen was wird
durchschnittseinkommen denn sie schaffen
jedoch nicht mehr den sprung zu einem
wirklich wohlhabenden land zu werden
länder wie brasilien kolumbien und eben
thailand scheint aufgrund dieser
situation zu stagnieren wenn du dich
erinnerst einer der wichtigsten
wirtschaftszweige thailand ist der
tourismus er macht mehr als zwölf
prozent des bip des landes aus und was
ist der sektor der am meisten vom kronos
betroffen war genau der tourismus aber
neben dem tourismus ist eine weitere
schlüsselindustrie des landes die
automobilindustrie und wie sieht es da
aus
[Musik]
entlässt alle 1500 werftarbeiter in
thailand nach dem verkauf seiner
fabriken wir reden hier nicht nur von
general motors auch der
motorradhersteller triumph hat werke in
thailand nicht gemacht und viele weitere
unternehmen drohen mit weiteren
werkschließungen
insgesamt ist die autoproduktion in
thailand im jahr 2020 und 30 prozent
eingebrochen seien bp ist mehr als zwölf
prozent gesunken all dies bedeutet dass
tausende von menschen arbeitslos
geworden sind doch das ist nicht das
einzige was ich in diesem land verändert
hat am anfang dieses videos habe ich dir
sechs versprochen hier kommt er
[Musik]
lockdown mit 20 6 soldatinnen theater
genau so hat der könig von thailand den
lockdown verbracht im 4 sterne hotel
hotel sonnenbichl der garmisch
partenkirchen welches er komplett für
sich und sein gefolge inklusive der 20
konkubinen gemietet hat und ich weiß
dass einige von euch einwänden werden
woher wisst ihr dass diese 20 frauen
konkubinen waren was wenn sie einfach
nur wirklich leibwächter waren oder dies
mädchen oder seine freundinnen nun die
wahrheit ist dass könig vajiralongkorn
eine lange und bekannte beziehung zu
diesen konkubinen pflegt
thailändischer playboy könig ernennt
geliebte zu seiner offiziellen konkubine
andere könige würden sagen dass sie eine
assistentin haben oder eine freundin der
teig könig ist da ganz offenherzig er
nennt sie seine sechs soldaten hat ihm
sogar den namen einer spezialeinheit der
britischen sas verpasst mit
militärischen rennen wie zb oberst
versehen und sie alle durchnummeriert
von 1 bis 20 so einfach ist das in
thailand es gibt sogar videos auf
wikileaks mal wirklich alles über diesen
könig sehen kann natürlich sind wir auf
visual politik nicht daran interessiert
über das sexleben von irgendjemandem zu
urteilen solange er keine gesetze bricht
kann dieser mann ja tun was er will aber
vergiss nicht dass er nicht nur ein
könig ist er ist auch rama der zehnte
nichts geringeres als ein gott
so ein gottes da sein bringt schon ein
wenig verantwortung mit sich schon mal
sehen und seine regierungszeit hatte
sich der vorherige könig rama der note
den respekt des thailändischen volkes
verdient in einer so konservativen
gesellschaft repräsentierten rama der
neunte rechtschaffenheit und disziplin
sein sohn stellt jedoch das genaue
gegenteil da er wurde bereits dreimal
geschieden hat vier uneheliche kinder
und hat obendrein seine lieblings pudel
zum general der luftwaffe ernannt
[Musik]
und fliegende hunde sind selbst für die
einigen exzentrisch muss gewöhnt heißt
einfach zu viel denn als ob das alles
nicht genug wäre will könig war der
zehnte noch nicht einmal in thailand
leben wie im jahr 2016 kaufte er die
villa stolberg im bayerischen tutzing am
starnberger see und will dort aus
thailand reagieren tatsächlich stellte
die ist eine seiner bedingungen für die
annahme der verfassung von 2017 da sie
mussten ihn von deutschland aus regieren
lassen die so aber hat rama so ein
faible für bayern nun schon sein
großvater war ein großer bewunderer des
deutschen kaisertums und großer
deutschland-fan irgendwie hat diese
familie das wohl in den genen und seiner
majestät bekommt das klima am
starnberger see wohl weitaus mehr zu als
das in bangkok bot ich weiß was du jetzt
denkst was weil dieser könig einfach
nicht regieren will er will einfach
nichts mit politik am hut haben und sein
eigenes leben leben und die realität ist
das genaue gegenteil
vor zwei wochen hat der thailändische
könig ein königliches dekret erlassen
dass zwei armee einheiten unter seine
direkte kontrolle stellt anstatt unter
die normale militärarchiv das ist
richtig rama der zehnte unter dem
schritte um die absolute monarchie in
thailand wieder herzustellen erlangt
mehr und mehr kontrolle über die armee
auf grund der protest in seinem
heimatland kette er sogar für über ein
jahr bayern den rücken und ging in das
land zurück welches er eigentlich
regiert thailand ja da muss ist ihm
schon ziemlich ernst sein bei den wahlen
2009 10 verbot er seiner schwester die
kandidatur zur ministerpräsidentin und
das ist noch lange nicht das krasseste
bis 2017 wurde das vermögen des
thailändischen königshauses vom kraut
property büro verwaltet eine institution
die dem finanzministerium unterstellt
ist um die reine vorstellung zu geben
dieses vermögen um fast so etwas wie
einen staatsfonds mit investition
unternehmen des landes zb sind die
thailändischen reue ist die
hauptaktionäre einer der größten banken
thailands der siam commercial welt nun
das erste was rama der zehnte tag sobald
er auch den ton kam war die volle
kontrolle über dieses amt zu übernehmen
es wird geschätzt dass diese institution
sich bis 100 milliarden dollar
kontrolliert die sich nun allein in den
händen des königs befinden aber das ist
noch nicht alles darüber hinaus wurde
auch seine königs gehalt erhöht ab 2021
wird der könig jährlich mehr als 1,1
milliarden dollar aus der thailändischen
staatskasse erhalten einfach so
weil er das land von bayern aus ja so
gut regiert mit anderen worten teil an
verfügt über alle zutaten für eine volks
revolte eine wirtschaftskrise eine
korrupte elite die das vertrauen der
mehrheit der bürger verloren hat und
einen starken oppositionsführer oder in
der lage ist all diese unzufriedenheit
zu kanalisieren was also fordern die
demonstranten ihre hauptforderung sind
abschaffung der unmenschlichen
blasphemiegesetz und transparenz
bezüglich des umgangs der krone mit
ihrem gewaltigen vermögenswerten
außerdem soll den könig verboten werden
staatsstreiche anzuzetteln naiven
westlern mögen diese forderungen sehr
moderat erscheinen aber vergiss nicht
dass wir hier über das vielleicht
monarchistisch bilanz der welt sprechen
und deshalb ist es so unglaublich dass
wir erst jetzt anfangen dinge wie diese
zu hören
thailändische demonstranten fordern das
ende der monarchie am geburtstag des
königs bald im hinterkopf dass wir nicht
nur über ein oder zwei proteste sprechen
die demonstration in thailand begann im
februar 2020 und im juli 2020 begannen
viele weitere menschen auf die straßen
zu gehen die proteste finden auf
öffentlichen plätzen und den
universitäten der wichtigsten städte
statt zwei große studentengruppen
brachen damals das hoch heilige kabul
der öffentlichen kritik an der monarchie
und seitdem erlebte das land bereits
vier monate lange wellen der proteste
den demonstranten geht es um nichts
weniger als um eine neudefinition der
eigenen nationalen identität
der bewegung liegt der starke wunsch zu
grund und neu zu begründen was ist
bedeutet thailänder zu sein es geht
darum sich von der totalen abhängigkeit
von der monarchie und des militärs zu
lösen das volk sollte uneingeschränkt
oberste souverän werden so wie in jeder
richtigen demokratie bisher forderte
dieser wunsch zwei todesopfer und mehr
als 150 verletzte bei versuchen von
armee und polizei die proteste zu
unterdrücken mehr als 580 menschen
wurden festgenommen und über 1600 vor
gericht gestellt doch die demonstranten
protestieren weiter und gerade zum
zeitpunkt als wir dieses video drehen
ist könig pharma wieder in deutschland
aufgetaucht scheinbar glaubt er seine
anwesenheit in teil eins seien nicht
mehr so wichtig angesichts der jüngsten
entscheidung des höchsten gerichts des
landes selbst friedliche proteste gegen
den könig müssten als hochverrat
gewertet werden jetzt ist also die frage
an dich gerichtet glaubst du dass diese
proteste einen echten wandel in thailand
bedürfen werden was denkst du über die
thailändischen monarchie und monarchien
im main denkst du dass es sich um eine
veraltete institution handelt oder hat
sich leicht doch einen platz in unserer
zeit und würdest du nach thailand ziehen
und dort ruhig gehen können wenn du
weißt welche politischen und
rechtsstaatlichen verhältnisse für die
thais dort herrschen die immer sind wir
auf all eure meinungen zu diesem thema
schon hochgradig gespannt ich hoffe also
dass euch dieses video gefallen hat was
ja gibt es mit einem like teilt es mit
euren freunden und vergesst nicht das
abo mit glöckchen um keines unser videos
mehr zu verpassen was gut und bis bald
[Musik]